fragen über fragen in fragen lotte
wieder die harmlosesten und die
gemeinsten zum beispiel die fünf jahre
hat doreen für ihr album gebraucht hat
sie eigentlich in der ganzen zeit sie so
auf der tasche gelegen und warum hat sie
überhaupt so lange gedauert und wann
kommt endlich komplett inkl sido und
doreen in love auf pro7 oder ladies
first theorien und sie so in love also
das und noch viel mehr wird sie jetzt
beantworten und wenn es euch gefällt und
ihnen nichts verpassen wollt von ihr und
anderen promis bei uns abonnieren da
oben müsste der banken seien nicht
vergessen zu klicken und jetzt viel spaß
so wir haben uns gesagt auch wenn es
regnet wir machen weiter wir ziehen das
durch es regnet wir machen weiter genau
das ist was fragen warum ich weiß du
weißt auch für die roten dinger sei ich
schon schiss vor du brauchst können ich
hätte bestimmt irgendwann immer gute
dinge nimmt man muss ja der luther ins
auge sehen und mache ich den müll hin
den gibst du mir geb ich einfach daneben
nachher nehmen wir den hörer mit
solches vorlese oma bist du so
unproduktiv oder warum hat ein album so
lange gedauert aber gute frau das ist
aber eine gute frage
hat sich ja bereits erwähnt jaja im
interview aber wir müssen sie so
attraktiv ok
das hat damit zu tun dass die
plattenfirmen so spät kapiert haben dass
ich doch eigentlich ganz gut bin ja soo
damit hat es glaube ich was zu tun ich
habe viele viele menschen kennengelernt
die halt nun mal das ist nicht so
geteilt haben jetzt habe ich menschen
kennengelernt dieses gefeilt haben und
deswegen bin ich erzählt ja mal sind wir
nach dem hit mit sido nein nicht die
bude eingerannt haben die wenigsten oder
höre ich glaube dass kam sogar kurz
danach ja ich weiß jetzt gar nicht so
zeit technisch und soja ich glaube das
war kurz danach genau haben sie gedacht
kann doch auch sie kann ja wat so und
dann dann ist es losgegangen dann ist es
ungefähr so in dem zwei jahre lang
gebraucht ich habe zwei jahre lang ein
album gemacht ja ja ich habe auch immer
wieder weggeschmissen und so nah weil
ich wollte dass das zu hunderten ich bin
das ist richtig und ich bin auch so eine
kleine perfektionist das muss alles so
soll ich jetzt hier wieder rein es gibt
es im modern leben und jetzt kommt seine
grüne farbe bekommt jetzt wie stehe ich
nehme mal eine grüne frage auf sind eine
nette frage der film aber auch schwierig
zu beantwortende fragen wie gewusst
deswegen gehe ja erst noch sehen
warum bist du einer der ganz wenigen
castingstars die immer noch ein
plattenvertrag hat
das ist voll krassen frage er das weiß
ich gar nicht wahr warum ist das so wer
warum haben denn nicht sie gehen ja eben
auch schnelligkeit das ist voll krass
dabei in deutschland ist dieses phänomen
ist nicht wie in amerika dass sie da
ihre stars dann so feiern wie dann beim
casting gewonnen so kelly clarkson und
instinkt und so dieser adressen sind wir
alles alles gecastete leute und in
amerika feiern die ihre stars dafür
total krass und in deutschland und wie
nicht in deutschland wollen die halt die
sendung sehen und das war es also die
die leute die die feiern hat die sendung
mehr denn eigentlich als den künstler
und alles drum rum was danach also
passiert und wir sind ganz stories die
man die ganzen produktionsfirmen da
solange die sind halt interessanter als
letzten endes die musik vielleicht also
so und denn die meisten künstler können
sich dann halt nicht halten wo man das
böse hat das was mit sehr gut ich denke
nicht dass das mit so zu tun also werden
auch relativ spät erst ein duett
aufgenommen daran wer schon vier
ausländer oder so zusammen ja also ich
glaube
ich glaub ich hab das kapiert einfach so
das business
ich nehme jetzt eine route ja höchst
duale öffnen oder nicht er möchte ich
gut
versorgt
also was intended also
wieso kann ich dir den müll
direkt die frage aus versehen doch aus
kannst du dich eigentlich unter so einem
megastar wie sie du überhaupt
selbstständig entwickelt ja das kann ich
ja weil ich ein eigenständiger mensch
bin und
er ja privat mein mann und er nur in der
öffentlichkeit siedlung ist das wegen
krieg ich das eigentlich auch ganz gut
hin so ich weiß nicht so erdrückend oder
dass es so eine konkurrenzsituation
gotteshaus schon wieder über
erfolgreiches album wird auch alles ohne
hat dass das so nie nie im land er ist
ein unglaublich talentierte
songschreiber und rapper und so und ich
schätze ihn ich schätze ihn als künstler
wie auch als als privatperson in meinem
leben ist da ist ja noch mal drin das
eine hat aber nichts mit dem anderen zu
tun also ich bin ich ich mache meine
musik ich mache ich mach komplett andere
musik gern wird verschiedene zielgruppen
das ist alles getrennt und es ist alles
super alles schön so
heiß kann ja sein dass so etwas eher
drücken ich habe selber schon durchaus
in der beziehung erlebt dass es so dass
es in beziehungen durchaus einen
konkurrenzkampf geben kann also ich
freue mich über alles was ich von ihm
höre und sehe
ich habe den film gesehen der bald kommt
den habe ich schon sehen und und der ist
so krass oh mein gott wer
kommt wir uns am 29 mal so ist es schon
ein dass natürlich habe ich das exklusiv
verraten ein das weiß man schon am 1
was machten was macht dich so
einzigartig
als sie den mann
ist ja ja ich meine ich kann ich jetzt
noch nicht so lange
was würde sie
so was ich selber sucht jede aber der
materie hat er dir schon mal irgendwie
so ich war ja gesagt
ausführlich erklärt warum wir die so
toll findet
jetzt kannst du ihn aber mal fragen wenn
du in das nächste mal da ist ja genau
das überleben das gucke ich mir dann
auch an ich mag so langsam nicht das ist
auch dass ich ja was soll man da
erzählte ich bin so wie ich bin ist
machbar sind absolut klar das selber
auch zu sagen und dann
können wir auch nur sehr wenig und backe
schön was dort ja
also ich kann mich schon feiern aber ich
kann auch nicht also
hat es jetzt hier so
also kommt um arbeiten also was denn
hier los
bäckerin vorlesen hier schnell heißt das
ja wir gucken mal bitte ja
gut die frage
hast du jetzt wieder fünf jahre auf der
tasche gelegen
ja also entschuldigung mal wird da habe
ich mich öffentlich ich liebe von
tatsächlich die ganze zeit von meiner
musik alte sachen ich lebe ich kann
davon zum glück leben sobald das ist der
hammer
du hast ein
paar platten verkauft
der krasseste was hat denn da eigentlich
schon mal einer für einige geht verraten
habe ich schon mal aber
also ich habe mal kurz davor dj ötzi hat
sich mal ein bisschen aber auch die
schauspiel hat geärgert eine frage die
schauspieler nicht gar so ein bisschen
wir haben hier die sind schon echt hier
der ich habe ihm gesagt kann man seine
musik vertragen
schon einzelne samaras album
wird das ich lache jetzt hier noch mehr
und daher habe ich jetzt öffentlich
jetzt einen guten titel ja ja noch nach
das steht hast du eigentlich irgend
etwas gelernt genau gut ja gute frage
keine antwort also ja also ja also ich
habe mir im prinzip ich habe mir die
singerei habe ja selber beigebracht und
das habe ich noch ich habe ungefähr ich
habe ja den jobs gemacht ich erzähl was
ich komme ursprünglich aus der
gastronomie also wieder mutter und
von ich vom vom klos putzen zeitungs aus
zeitungen austragen flyer verteilen hier
so einer hand an einer brandenburger
noch damals
die macht die kap alles gemacht ich
hab's ja mal radio promo ist er wieder
funktioniert celik lieber nicht mehr da
manche menschen enttäuscht
die karateka packt alles gemacht kämpfen
gehabt ich habe alles immer dazu
ziemlich anders sehen nie gelernt
ich habe es mir selber an gelernt habe
ich nie
ich wollte ich immer also ich habe ja
damals mein abi abgebrochen wegen kopf
saß und das war also ich hätte sonst
noch gemacht ich habe mein abitur fast
egal egal egal sind das was ich jetzt
mache brauche aber ich hätte mein abitur
fertig gemacht dann hätte dein gesang
studiert also person also derselbe weg
geworden und willst du nicht mal das
nicht manchmal denkst ich sollte mal ein
paar gesagt zurücknehmen weil es damals
atmung stimme klar wenn man muss sich
immer weiterentwickeln und so auf jeden
fall klar war sondern gelebt sowieso nie
stehen also ich lerne immer dazu
bei der frage ist amy macdonald ein
bisschen weiß schon was daraus geworden
ist nicht das was ich kann mir so was
nicht merken ach ja das erste mal bei
der anderen frage ob sie überhaupt was
gelernt hat die hat nicht auch selber
bei geworden die hat ja auch eine tolle
stimme ja wir wollen das nicht gar nicht
um gottes willen ich finde es auch gar
nicht ich bin noch voll stolz vor wir
also ich bin
okay wann mein charakter brillen nicht
auf
ich habe denke ich kann ja nicht gucken
ich kann nicht gut so kurz weiter ich
bin ich bin kurzsichtig ich bin
kurzsichtig und trotzdem sehe ich nahm
mittlerweile auch nicht mehr gut ja das
geht doch alle griechen hier
wann sehen wir endlich dorin und sie nur
in live auf prosieben
das ist so krass niemals oder wird
wahrscheinlich schon angefragt niemals
ja klar klar nicht nur einmal aber
niemals niemals nicht das ist ja meine
beziehung ist ok tv show das ist mein
leben das vermag ich nicht so bin ich
das jetzt zwei grüne noch ein gotteshaus
dieses ist könnte es könnte doch es
könnte auch nicht werden das könnte
richtig nicht werden das hat ja auch
aufgehört zu regnen halo hat das na ja
aber wenn wir es durchgezogen haben
sowieso da kenne ich nicht
so jetzt pass auf
warum hast du immer an dich geglaubt
habe ich gar nicht immer
gerne zwei fan war es praxis zu zweifeln
dann weiß ich nicht aber ich glaube ich
glaub ich hab ich habe ewig gebraucht
bis ich so bissig also jeder jedes kind
in der pubertät so zweifelt an sich
sucht den weg und guckt wo selber der
platz ist im leben so und ich haben
durchgehend immer so an mich geglaubt es
gab auch mal tiefen wo wo man sich
selber einfach finden muss und so aber
ich habe relativ früh gemerkt dass es
sich dass es sich lohnt dran zu bleiben
und weiter zu üben und weiter mut zu
machen und dann kam mit den jahren auch
das selbstbewusstsein und dann musste
ich auch was sich für musik machen
möchte um was ich überhaupt sagen möchte
und letzten endes bin ich darauf
gekommen dass ich einfach über mich
redet so also dass ich mainz verarbeitet
und das macht eigentlich selbst sicher
so also sind sowieso wenn man wenn man
nichts gutes zu sagen hat oder wenn man
sich nicht auskennt sollte man die
klappe halten ich weiß was über mich
deswegen rede ich über mich ich glaube
ja sowieso dass das durchhaltevermögen
entscheidend ist für jede art von erfolg
dieses ist doch immer wer gewinnen will
muss verliert so sich das auch
wer stark sein will muss schwäche zeigen
können so richtig
das ist ja ein
warum hast du dir mit deinem ersten
album so viel mühe gegeben weil das mein
erstes album 2 ob man jetzt muss ich
warte mal nicht dass sie krieg nie
wieder von plattenfirma decca währung
na weil
man das so macht also ich meine es ist
ja mein erstes album so man hat ja am
anfang von tuten und blasen keine ahnung
habe mein erstes album mit produzenten
hier und alles und so einen song
schreibe ich habe einfach gemacht und
dann habe ich gemerkt hier und da das
könnte noch besser sein als jahr
weggeschmissen ab nämlich so dass jetzt
sechsmal so viel geld
das ist schon hart vor allen dingen wäre
so songs sind an die man ja selber das
ist ja alles geschichten so von mir und
wenn man die denn wegschmeißt und wieder
neues macht man denkt aber die
geschichte wollte ich doch eigentlich
auch erzählen dass auch fall wichtig so
gehört doch auch zu mir eigentlich egal
ob dann gleich wieder stoff für zweite
album so und
habe ich mir so finden ich gebe mir so
viel mühe weil das ja das ist ja auch
mein leben ist meine existenz davon
davon thomas d hat mal gesagt
er lebt durch von und für die musik und
ich glaube so trifft das auch auf mich
zukommen
oder ja vielen dank das hat mich ganz da
freue ich mich auch wenn du ein bisschen
pikante fragen gestellt